we had the onstage act we have our own
private chaser ice concert she loves
country the ghost me return the fries
and the tears of pain and I've heard so
many story until they break my heart
this is your bachelor season 24 episode
4 recap grab your glasses it's time for
Rose is that rose
hey hi everybody it's me Lauren Zima can
you find a rose does anybody see a rose
where's Waldo's roses I'm wearing a
shirt entirely covered in roses that's
what I'm talking about you guys it's
wonderful how many roses are on this
shirt and this was a wonderful episode
of The Bachelor a bit of a horror movie
vibe to it I'm gonna get him set I'll
explain why it's scary how many roses
are on this shirt so I could have gone
either way with the pine I had to make
it in my decision and let's get to it I
have a different glass this week we're
trying all sorts of new glasses this
one's rose-colored so we're being also
very literal roses say you know it's
kind of fun is you can't see how much
I'm pouring in here ready to I'm caught
just like Victoria was she I don't know
we'll get into it which Victorian I've
been talking about so many options oh it
was a good episode wasn't it what did
you guys think of this app let me know
in the comments below I loved it why
ladies it's time to pack up Oh
then Chris Harrison comes in with some
news we're going to Cleveland
in Cleveland Ohio so we are leaving the
mansion and going to Cleveland I really
appreciated that this time around they
didn't have the ladies fake that
excitement you know in the past they'll
be like Wichita and everyone's like and
this time they just kept it honest you
know Cleveland but drink every time
someone's like please worst
I think of Ohio I don't necessarily
think romance is there like something
like hidden gems in Cleveland that we're
not aware of
mm-hmm actually right off the bat great
b-roll of Cleveland it looked lovely a
cool sign a bridge a downtown I'm
looking forward to see my ladies
speaking of things that are looking good
are we keeping tabs on Peter's scruff
versus beard situation I really had my
eye on at this episode because last week
Kelly told Peter straight up that she
likes a scruff better than a bee or more
of the scruffy girl
Kelly the lawyer I do not object is that
I agree with you completely and Peter
really seems to be teetering doesn't
mean he's really walking the line is it
scruff or is it a beard is it enough or
is it too much is it a full face or is
it a grizzly man you know what I'm
saying but I think he's nailing it let
me know in the comments below
before I ask to Victoria F is getting
our first one-on-one and Peter is going
to take Victoria F flying are you flying
in every episode doesn't Peter from his
travels have any pilot friends in any of
these cities maybe someone else could
get into the cockpit for a moment he
could be in the back having a snack you
know I just think doesn't he want
something to eat or drink on these dates
because they're additionally going to an
amusement park and rollercoasters are
happening by the way don't drink every
time Victoria F freaking loses her mind
in this episode she's losing her mind in
the car before the plane she's losing
her mind on the plane she's losing her
mind on the roller coaster she's losing
her mind at the concert we're gonna get
to it okay I don't know but they wind up
alone in this diner and it was honestly
a little unsettling they have the whole
amusement park to themselves which is
cool but just alone in this town it felt
a bit like a horror thing didn't it even
though I found that unsettling though
what I found perhaps most disturbing was
Victoria's toast
she made a toast to her and Peter's
unborn son to our daughters not good
enough and to their successful dad and
hot mom hot moms Victoria can't you be
successful too you know I had to ask
myself the deep emotional question of
the week what are we cheersing to you
know what are we celebrating I will say
they are looking at each other with a
lot of connection aren't they drink
every time you saw Peter in Victoria
looking deeply and passionately into
each other's eyes a lot of chemistry it
scary to see your face
you have no idea what's coming yes then
we see a very different type of look in
Victoria's eyes as Peter tells her that
they are now going to get a private
concert in Rose country and she's asking
who will be performing at this private
concert she's walking towards the stage
and hearing the twang of country music
slowly spilling out over the speakers
it's sounding but familiar isn't it as
though she's perhaps met this person
before her eyes are widening as she's
saying who who Peter who is praying for
us Peter who will it be and it is God
what an episode I really I
cheers to the producers that's worth
tears into and shares to that cameraman
who kept his camera locked in on
Victoria's wide eyes and wet hair she
strolled through that sad dark parking
lot towards a fate that she didn't see
coming and wouldn't want to accept don't
drink again because Victoria F is really
freaking out now she says of her ex
chase rice performing the concert for
her and Peter quote nothing could be
worse
nothing the doers so Peter and Victoria
come out to the concert and chase Rice's
there what did you guys think of chases
faces during all this did he know that
he would be performing for Victoria and
Peter we need to meet Victoria didn't
say later in the episode that she told
chase she was going on the show but did
he agree to perform before that after
did he know it would be a date with
Victoria let me know in the comments
below and oh god drink for every painful
painful thing that Peter unknowingly
said like oh you know this song
she's like they do I know every word it
might even be about her oh this is the
point in the show where you need a drink
and shears two more I work because then
it's Victoria and chase who are looking
into each other's eyes as he sings
Victoria is looking like oh god what am
I gonna do and Victoria's just still
dancing still tense I keep tasting Peter
doesn't know dancing and chases who I'm
writing new lyrics in my head for what
I'm gonna get out of this moment and be
just like Oh God and now Peter is
talking to chase right soon you're gonna
clean up a bit like an elevator like a
dinner portion kind of we're serious
like when is someone going to tell Peter
you know when do you guys think Victoria
should have told Peter I think it should
have been right when they walked out
just say it right from that point you
know because now every moment they had
together is going to ring false to Peter
in retrospect then it gets worse
theatres exchanging numbers with chase
rice to be they are gonna be best
friends so gonna be flying him in a
plane soon you know Peter and chase Rhys
might be dating I don't know now
Victoria and chase are talking and he's
telling her he didn't know this was
gonna happen
and she says she doesn't want it to be a
thing and Victoria it's the thing if you
make it all better freakin oh and
Victoria says she's freaking out it's
like girl we know you're always painting
Peter says that maybe chase rice could
sing at him and Victoria's wedding
things keep going like this you know we
could have chase rice sing at our
wedding there you go
someone tell Peter hours later it's ours
Victoria and Peter are going to dinner
and she is finally telling Peter chase
nine City and oh my god his face he's
like Peter's so confused he's like chase
the sandwiches
the singer chase barely was in the
concert the guy at the concert yeah no
one on stage and what the man singing
that chase I mean of course Peters
confused he exchanged numbers with Chase
they told each other their life stories
they figured out 10 friends they have in
common and he was going to sing at
Peter's wedding Victoria there you go
you never know
should have told him soon yeah Peter
even says no no like his person is
rejecting this information you know I
think that we actually witnessed
something wild I believe we saw the
moment that Peter realized he was on
this show he says this is so freaking
weird one dear ones you like to dance
they go to someone else's eggs yeah on
the bachelor Peter yeah you're on the
shuttle and you're the lead yeah
after the same time I was like I didn't
want to ruin the moment cuz I knew the
hero's happy
so again Victoria is freaking out and
she leaves and then we are back in the
Hilton of Cleveland and McKenna and we
find out Kelsey's getting a one-on-one
and I did not expect that did you
oh I like its surprises McKenna is upset
that she didn't get the day but I think
that Peters putting McKenna on the back
burner a little bit because he knows
that he likes her don't you think let me
know in the comments below so back to
Victoria and Peter and Peter is actually
all good with this I do think Peter
understands now that he's on this
reality show and so is she
and that on this unparalleled reality
show that I love so much people get put
into dramatic situations so he forgives
Victoria did you think he should have I
thought it was great and Victoria was
honest with him she just could have been
a little more honest little sooner so
then they're making out and their
connection really felt real to me what
did you guys think I think now Victoria
F is an F for frontrunner I'm liking the
season because we're getting new
frontrunners every episode what's tricky
my god
I've always liked Peter but I really
fell for him on this episode you guys he
says let's just laugh it off you know I
mean Peter is a nice guy he's mature
he's successful he's very positive and
he can have a laugh I think Peters a
real catch Victoria
yeah well you not run in a corner anyway
Victoria F gets a rose and one more
concert that cellist isn't one of her
exes right and then I've got a drink
because we're onto the group date and
Peter says he's so excited to share
shares ladies what I have planned for
today then it is this is Josh Cribbs
this guy is a legend as we do on every
one of these dates they've brought in
some athletes that we don't know and
we're gonna cheer we're gonna clap for
them at least we were honest about her
reaction to Cleveland oh we're not
coming out not a reaction to these
athletes that we don't recognize you
know I always think I was standing out
what would be going through my head is
there a snack bar here I wonder if they
have wine maybe it's that individual
sized wine where you get kind of a whole
small bottle for herself
where is the wine luckily someone's into
this Tammy says she loves contact sports
I'm so frickin excited I love football
I love context works Oh Tammy what a
champ I really do like her
i'ma tackle a lot of [ __ ] I think
she's paradise material mmm let me know
in the comments below if I'm being
honest I'm a very terrified a whole so
drink for every time McKenna doesn't
catch the ball
I felt that McKenna
so anyway I'm just gonna play it safe
you know what cheers - Victoria PE
because she got out of it she said she
had a back injury I'm not gonna do this
today because of my back so and she just
fully sits out and not only that then
she gets one-on-one time and a massage
with Peter well played Victoria these
guys this isn't sports this is a whole
lot of game I'm gonna feel about you
think there was something about you
Peter with his big statements tells her
he hasn't stopped thinking about her Wow
I may be sick Cleveland's John does
alongside radio host Morgan right and
then Oh someone else is announcing this
game where is Chris Harrison
did not like this at all these people
did not understand and here we are it is
the bachelor Bowl 2019 yeah we're
announcing the game like it's really a
game saying things like touchdown by the
eliminators and winning the eliminators
have retaken the lead in other sports
words Jimmy takes the snap
yes Harrison knows how to announce a
sporting event for bachelor nation he
gives this vague color commentary
interspersed with clever Joe
[Applause]
go killer bees this coach athlete man is
like this everybody understand and I
would have said absolutely not okay now
it's the cocktail party I think some
stuffs gonna go down Cheyenne's down
Peter Cass so you first I can victoria
piece steals peter right away and you
know the women are not gonna like that
because booth was sat out at that game
and she already had some alone time with
Peter you're the first one I take you
away I like to see that Peter does like
it you guys Peter likes bold women we've
learned that he gave Hannah and the
first impression rose on night one when
she kept stealing him he tells Victoria
P he likes this he told me that he liked
it for a woman in an interview shameless
blue and then this horror movie of an
episode continues of ghost is here
[Music]
what is happening there's a ghost to the
room Malaya has arrived though we didn't
know this was happening because it was
in the teaser last week for this week's
episode like I wish they hadn't spoiled
it to be honest man I sent her up but
Peter didn't know because look at his
scruff covered face and then McKenna is
trying to cast a spell with her hands to
get rid of the ghost of a lay I what is
happening
I'm here to freakin set the record
straight about my upset about me but
ghost Leia comes back with something to
say she says that Peter was manipulative
you kind of let yourself get manipulated
do you agree
and Aleya has even more to say she says
that Victoria P is lying about their
level of friendship I was in physical
shock that she could even say that but
it was more than three hours
Randeep we've been friends since she was
permissive easy Ana drink for every
receipts that Alea had to say hard I
planned a trip to Vegas together once we
talked every day before leading up to
this is Maria P yes Toria pol yes you
can believe that or you can believe me
I'm telling you that my truth is the
truth what did you guys think of what
Victoria P had to say to Peter all of a
sudden she's saying yes I went to Vegas
with Olay it's together in like hell
she's saying she told him her truth but
her truth is changing isn't it a long
thing and that makes me question that
you know let me know in the comments
below
Peter look at me she's like Oh get me
Peter
then she starts crying who do you
believe oh and drink for all the
receipts now a woman whose name I just
learned - Savannah is saying that
Victoria Pete was saying horrible things
about Alea and a closet I know the
things that she said in the closet
she's a charity person and then holding
her hand during the rose ceremony and I
wrote down cut to a deep hug what
everyone is confused Peter is confused
I'm confused everyone is confused what
is the relationship between Alea and
Victoria Peak I do think that they are
two women who did pageants and that they
were trained to speak vaguely when
needed so now when we require the truth
out of them it's very convoluted it's
very confusing they're not really
falling on one side or the other and I
am current knowing that we have so many
friends together
why is everyone touching each other it's
like we're all grasping for reality but
Victoria peers are reaching over to LA
as I to remove something that's not
there in an attempt to show how nice she
is how caring how thoughtful I don't
believe it
I really turned on Victoria P all of a
sudden you guys this is a roller coaster
of an episode just like that Cedar Point
and we are in a nightmare
yeah except this rose because Peter
gives her the rose is this the first for
the show historians let me know in the
comments below what do you think of this
decision it's a sequel Alea is getting a
Friday the 14th well the internet knows
everything I will tell you all let me do
what I really adore we break the fourth
wall it happens on occasion
Alea said that she's been out there in
the real world I need you guys to catch
me up on everything because I've only
seen one oh I know and she's seen what
the Internet has seen and she tells
everyone or Trey enough had a yesterday
I know she was dating chase race before
the date what Oh y'all don't know that
that Victoria F was the with Chase right
then back to the light it's Kelsey's
one-on-one day with Peter and we're
still dancing in every episode but this
is perfect isn't it because we said we
were going to start doing a two-step
alley and Peter literally tells Kelsey
he's going a teacher a two-step they
never stop dancing they danced through
the streets the city of Cleveland has
really turned it out with a variety of
activities from Peter and Kelsey anybody
go to Cleveland
oh they have food they have racing is
there wine nice quick vlog I'm back in
my shades to say something I forgot
Kelsey
she gave us the iconic champagne moment
and then this week she served maturity
and groundedness if you feel like you
need to explore this more and rather how
do you do that now on our one-on-one
date with Peter Kelsey for Bachelorette
Oh finally I had to endure so many
sports oh oh and I love Peters outfit a
nice turtleneck with a very classic kind
of a businessman coat I adored this look
what did you think I want to know all
about you so Kelsey is telling her story
and now I'm a Kelsey Stan my opinion is
changing a lot this season Peter was
really listening which I loved
his best face of the night and I heard
so many stories so they break my heart
of what my mom I'm like ever had to go
through oh god Peter is crying he does
turtleneck I love him talking about his
mom of course she's the best so we're
gonna see her cry don't think about it
Lauren is too scary don't think about it
you ring for every sequel in this
episode Alea return and Kelsey gets the
next chapter you know she gets the Rose
what a turnaround what a night at the
movies but sequels are always
continuations of the original stories
and once again the women are saying that
Alea is full of crap you're
we're not going to come in here after
being sent home
they say she's manipulative she spread
the story about Victoria Evans chase
what did you guys think
once again I thought that Alea was being
treated a little bit unfairly she seems
to have come back in and she just
mentioned the Victoria after chase thing
I don't think she knew that no-one knew
a lot of drama but I wrote down at least
everyone sitting around drinking wine
and for us who went on the group date
who bust our ass out there on the
football field and literally have the
physical bruises to show and oh wow now
these women are really mad because they
are telling Peter Elena got that rose
then walking hand-in-hand with Alia it
was like the biggest slap in the face
like I couldn't even look at you and
this is why I don't do sports i bruise
like a peach okay go talk to her I don't
really don't talk to her nobody I can
you go and talk now Victoria's mad at
Peter I wrote down I don't really know
why this felt like an overreaction to me
she doesn't want to talk but she does
she doesn't want to sit under the seat
I can't fit but she did it read to me
like she was just trying to exert some
power over Peter and just get into a
fight with him it's ruining all of her
time I don't want to be in a
relationship with someone that calls me
a liar and then wants a back got these
women are lampooning Peter at this point
we are in saw 10 Sydney is mad at him
because he doesn't know her middle name
you don't know what my middle name is
Sydney calm down
honestly I mean if that's your priority
of concern yes use this time to talk to
Peter instead of yelling at him what did
you guys think were they right to be
angry about Peter using his time on Alea
and other things or did they just need
to calm down like every horror movie we
are left on a to be continued but of
course we get a trailer for next week
and we have seen a lot of sexuality a
lot of sexuality in the water and
speaking of water Tami crying now that's
a horror movie
why'd you do it
Tammy when she could do everything that
girl she's giving us laughter she's
given a sports she's giving us sexy vibe
she's making out with Peter but she's
also playing the game oh oh guys Wow the
last thing I wrote down was wow wow did
you like this episode let me know in the
comments below
oh I simply adore all of you thank you
for watching thank you for your
interaction with me please follow me on
Instagram and Twitter I live tweet the
episodes every Monday and of course
check out roses and rose' on
entertainment tonight's broadcast show
every Tuesday night where we do a bit of
a different show I talk about other
things make new jokes and we have
special guests after all that scariness
I need a snuggle I'm gonna go to bed I'm
gonna see you ghost
goodnight and
[Music]